this video is sponsored by ridgewallet
2020 has been a
wild year and i don't mean wild as in
[Music]
no what i mean is this
you see in case you missed it over the
course of this year's various lockdowns
i managed to catch up on one of the most
intimidating manga series to catch up on
for any fan
one piece and in doing so i managed to
acquire not only a fantastic new story
to occupy my time with
not only did i find a new wholesome
community to engage within
but i also acquired the ability to
finally say that i have seen
every single one piece
um okay as i was saying i don't have a
single shred of one-piece material left
to one
okay this isn't cool who keeps cutting
me off yo
one piece is the best series i've ever
read in my life first impressions of
photos
hey i'm not doing the one-piece movies
you can't make me
lockdown's almost over i've already read
a thousand chapters
there are other series i need to get to
like jojo's bizarre adventure or hunter
hunter and besides
there's like 14 of them
specials okay how could i forget and
refresh my memory how many of them are
there exactly
so what you're telling me is i need to
watch and review
27 movies oh yeah or else what
what are you going to do oh yeah you
know what
this isn't too bad
you win i'll review the movies just
please for the love of god stop
using windows movie maker
well it seems 2020 is the year that
keeps on giving and seeing as i spent
most of 2020 reviewing one piece and
since i've already covered all the
dragon ball films it only seems fair to
cover these two
though i'm gonna put my foot down here i
refuse to review stories that recap
any arc that has already been covered in
the anime or manga besides even while
doing that it still leaves 12 movies and
9 specials for me to get to
but you know what who cares if this
one-piece journey has given me anything
it's still i can't cover all the films
in this one video because let's face it
even i'm not that crazy
so without further ado i'm totally not
mark and these are my first impressions
of thoughts on and review for the
surprisingly good
funny and maybe not so good one piece
movies
one to four let's get it
movie one entitled one piece the movie
is a 2d animated feature film produced
and distributed by toei animation
released on march 4th on the year 2000 i
was 8 years old when this came out it's
about 51 minutes long and was written by
michiro shimeda who had been pretty much
working on the one piece series as a
writer
since the second episode of the series
so if nothing else i'm expecting these
characters to feel consistent with the
series the film itself was directed by
junji shimizu
and we will be seeing that name quite a
lot in this video
as he is responsible for directing the
first three films
for that reason i really hope he's good
however considering this is the second
film he had
ever worked on as a director with the
first being 1996's
hell teacher the movie which got a
whopping 5.8 on imdb
to say the least i am nervous oh also
funnily enough
through my research for this guy i also
noticed that this guy actually worked on
an episode of dragon ball super
what episode to be in fact and what
episode was that episode 5
which to be honest from a storyboarding
perspective wasn't half bad
i just hope it's not a bad omen for how
this movie will look
okay here we go in a similar way to all
the other dragon ball films one piece
the movie takes heavy inspiration from
what details have been disclosed most
recently in the anime to formulate a
plot
in the same way the one piece series
began with the legend of gold roger this
two begins with the legend of
and i quote the great gold pirate wunan
and the legend surrounding his mountain
of gold complete with a secret island
only accessible through a treasure map
it's a really straightforward and
borderline cliche angle for a pirate's
story but you know what
i'm here for it and you know what else
the op we are plays and my
soul is filled with happiness because
that song is an absolute
bop overall i really like this movie it
opens with a really funny scenario
filled with character as luffy nami
usop and zoro all get their chance to
establish their characters for new
viewers who stops fishing nami's
navigating luffy's
being luffy additionally i like that we
are starting from a point where nami and
the crew are already looking for wunan's
island
but all is not well as luffy and the
crew are starving they get bordered by
this small group of pirates that steal
their treasure
while they are fighting over a single
grain of rice which on its own is a
funny visual but it also acts as the
impetus for the splitting up
of the crew in this short story in
trying to get the gold back
luffy and zora end up paddling to our
sea restaurant with a young boy who
really wants to be a pirate
also the restaurant is owned and
operated by his grandpa
nami ends up trailing the pirates that
stole her treasure in the first place
and their captain
el drago he really likes gold and that's
pretty much his character
as nami trails him however to the island
usa finds his way into navigating the
island with these evil pirates somehow
overall the new characters that have
been introduced seem sort of ill-defined
or
overly simplistic however with that said
there is still a lot of terrific humor
whether it was usa pretending to catch a
fish the crew fighting over a single
grain of rice or luffy realizing that
these are bad guys after he gets shot in
the head
this film regardless of how strong its
narrative is which seems
okay at this point it's more than worth
checking out for the character
interactions alone
once usopp integrates into this group he
gets sort of captured slash
hired by the el drago pirates luffy and
zoro can't pay for their meal and
nami follows two all of these plot lines
are now converging on this one location
the island of gold which
is great because really i found the only
interesting characters to be the straw
hat pirates and they do phenomenally
well bouncing off of each other and
seeing as this film is set during a time
where the straw hats still haven't left
the east blue the fact i get to
experience some lying usap and
money-grubbing nami
working side by side is always a treat
though i will say there was a moment
during the usa being taken hostage
section where
i wasn't sure how i felt about the
character looking at the camera and
poking
fun it sucked me out of the movie and
made me start thinking about deadpool or
space jam
they're about my baseball player now
right and i'm a shakespearean actor
thankfully though these moans are
short-lived and very sparse and at the
halfway point all four of the straw
hats finally reconnect but not before
luffy had been running around the forest
tied to zorro their dynamic
is honestly extremely refreshing and
always fun to listen to scenes like
these where luffy introduces himself to
el drago
had me burst out laughing
in terms of plot and history we are
greeted by one flashback
as it happens the young boy's
grandfather knew wound very well
and had a falling out with him when they
were kids but not before saving his life
years back thanks to a flag wound made
for both himself
and his friend which is nice and
everything but the story doesn't dwell
too long or focus on the plot
necessarily that is
until the very end tying things down and
moving on to the third act
two fights take place and one of them i
can barely call a fight at all
zoro pretty much dominates and one shots
el drago's second in command and despite
luffy having greater difficulty with the
captain
he makes fast work of him too out of the
two fights luffy's fight is easily the
most engaging and makes use of some
really fun rubber man powers capping off
the film however we're greeted with a
short scene wherein the straw hat
pirates
the young child and his grandpa all
discovered the remains of vunan along
with his last will and testament in it
he outlines that over the course of a
long career as a pirate he achieved his
dreams of gathering a mountain of gold
but through living that life realized
that there was so much more to life
than gold and i think that message fits
and ties nicely with the grandpa's
message to his grandson which ends up
being to pursue his life
the way he wants all in all this film's
greatest strengths were found in the
character writing and interactions
predominantly which i did anticipate and
while i don't think the various plot
lines mix very well and the antagonist
felt very
flat in one note the visual presentation
was consistent the script was beaming
with personality and the ending had a
simple but
sweet message all the while set in a
section of the story
i hadn't gotten to experience since the
beginning of my one piece journey
earlier this year
which was strangely nostalgic it's
nothing special but it's a fun little
film that doesn't last too long to
outstay its welcome
worth checking out but only if you're a
big fan of the characters or series
the second film one piece adventures on
clockwork island
one piece adventures on clockwork island
is a 2001 2d
animated feature film released march 3rd
of that year and was produced once again
by toei animation
it's about 55 minutes in length and was
written by hiroshi hashimoto this would
be
only his second ever time writing for
one piece with the first being a tv
special a year prior
because of this i didn't really feel the
same connection to the characters
in this film and i'm going to say that
from the outset having looked into his
background it seems as though he's not
worked on much at this point in his
career with the most scripting work
coming his way through the hit anime
yuyu haku show
in the early 90s but with that said this
film
really surprised me in a good way now
it's nothing super complicated
essentially it follows a plot where one
character is kidnapped and they gotta
get after them
and to be honest when this movie
establishes its opening
i wasn't a massive fan of it
though i want to preface this by saying
this movie
really surprises me in a good way later
that retroactively makes the opening
much better unlike the last film which
had the crew run into trouble with
unsavory characters because they were
both in the same area looking for the
same treasure
this film starts off with the crew
losing their ship aimlessly pursuing its
vague direction for a week with no
success
before randomly running into a couple of
thieves that happen to know the ship
know who took the ship and who are going
in the same direction the ship is in
for seemingly totally unrelated reasons
which when watching this for the first
time this felt like a pretty contrived
opening but not one that ruined my
experience
and i got over it pretty quickly
thankfully i did because it gets much
better and makes much more sense
later however once the plot gets moving
this film begins to show
why it's worth checking out the action
and animation
ramp up in a big way it's obvious that
this film's scope is much bigger and has
a vastly different cast of animators
working on it as soon as the straw hats
begin throwing hands with the very
pirates they've identified as thieves
there's some wonderful action-filled
tracking shots following various
characters as they both fight and run
away from their respective opponents
culminating with the bad guy pirates
taking with them an unconscious nami
wearing luffy's hat
it should also be noted at this point
that zoro's swords were on the
merry-go-also and thus they need to go
after the thieves to get back those too
it's essentially a smorgasbord of
motivations by which the straw hats will
be drawn into conflict to fight and
this is when we meet the bad guy of the
film and this bad guy
looks ridiculous his name is bear king
and he's building a large cannon so that
one day he can become the king of the
pirates too
he wants nami as his bride all the while
luffy and co
are making their way up spiral tower now
clock town the town surrounding the
spiral
is really pretty and the architecture in
general in this film is top notch
there's a decent amount of work having
gone into this town surrounding the
tower to enjoy for
any viewer but on a dialogue front
there's a really sweet interaction
between luffy his crew and these two
folks that look like they have ice cream
on their heads in it these two try to
encourage luffy and them to run
citing that their life will be worthless
if they die luffy
says it's worthless if they run too and
despite what i said about the character
interactions and the writing front
this film really does succeed in a lot
of ways in getting those biting pieces
of dialogue and insight into luffy's
character
so it has that going in his favor too at
this point the crew are floating up to
the destination to confront bear king
when
someone fires at them and this happens
[Music]
i was not expecting this to be this
graphic i mean
look at all that blood it looks so
painful and i winced when i saw it first
needless to say sanji gets captured and
the rest float up in the balloon they
stop outside the gates of the main
building and
i like how luffy sees a lot of himself
in shanks in these two that have
accompanied them on this adventure
he treats the kid tough but only because
he wants him to be tougher it sort of
reminds me of the same dynamic he had
with shirahoshi and fishman island only
that happens much much after this film
as the film progresses they break
through the gates and start fighting a
bunch of dudes
sanji is left hanging above the
courtyard in a crucifix which is a
weird decision to make for a bad guy to
do but you know what it's a film and
it's happening
usopp gets captured while being brave
and now both he and sanji are crucified
above the tower there's some brilliant
character animation action animation and
so much movement top to bottom in this
film and because of that it feels much
more premium than the first one for me
which
felt a little more like a long episode
of anime it's at this moment however the
story actually picks up
and swerved me considerably the
grievances i had at the beginning for
the less than believable auspicious
circumstances that befell our crew
were actually not convoluted at all but
in fact a planned by
the two people who met them at the
beginning having stolen their ship
the grown man barod wanted to use them
to return the child to his birthplace on
this island i actually didn't see that
coming
at all i thought this was going to be a
one-trick film but
it's not it's narratively solid too the
story isn't super exciting by any means
and it's pretty cliche in it being a
rescue raid the castle type story but
the writer decided to add a bit of
effort and spice into this tale which
i'm
honestly very happy about and what's
better is that this borough guy throws
luffy's line about running away
back at him which is a nice little
cherry on the top of this that i never
expected and this is all happening by
the way when luffy and zara are on the
verge of being crushed by this ceiling
and this is when
zorro gets attacked by one of the
henchmen under
bear king's control and now suddenly
there's some decent tension too
zoro is down and now it's just luffy on
his own with all of his crew ready to be
crucified
still not sure why that has to be like
that but okay all the while they ready
to use this big king
cannon and that's when the kid wakes up
near luffy who informs them that perrod
went to fight the card pirates alone the
kid runs towards the action
leaving luffy alone again struggling to
hold the ceiling we cut to the main
chamber where the bear king is charging
his cannon to fire when suddenly baro
arrives on the scene covered in
explosives however despite his
intentions
bear king thrashes him about and disarms
the situation at this point in the film
everything starts coming together in a
really nice way like
throughout this film luffy has seen
himself in the little kid and has tried
to encourage him in a direction that
he thought might benefit him which has
unfortunately led him into the chamber
to defend borrowed unable to do anything
against him
armed only with a brave good intention
his fate is
seemingly sealed
this was a cool as heck scene followed
by luffy accidentally getting the rest
of the crew free
in a dangerous and convenient way but
it's only a small thing so i'm not too
bothered by it it was done i'm assuming
as a way to lighten the mood after a
somewhat tense moment
what follows this is a series of short
but extremely well animated fight scenes
with each individual straw hat duking it
out with another henchman from the card
pirates
first up is sanji vs spiky ball man
again i'm terrible at remembering these
secondary character names so
he's spikey ball man again this fight is
short-lived but the choreography is
wonderful and it's
stupidly well animated usopp versus
flying
fart man was a super short but fun
little skirmish
featuring some good old-fashioned lying
on behalf of usopp as well as some
attacks from his classic arsenal
like the rotten eggs it's nostalgic to
see this zoro's fight with scarface men
was also a little disappointing
the animation wasn't bad just a lot more
limited than the other battles thus far
still though it served its purpose and
made zoro look super cool in the process
which
is why most people love them at the end
of the day and finally before the big
big fight between luffy and bear king
nami was given the short end of the
straw and simply
locks her opponent shiny water girl into
a jar with lots of tape
that's it it's literally like three
seconds okay onto the main event i guess
luffy vs bear king is the fight that has
been built up to throughout this film
and early on in their tussle it's
established that he has a body of steel
and cites that a rubber man stands no
chance against him that is
essentially the prevailing narrative
going into this confrontation
and it's observing how luffy's navigates
his way out of this situation that would
be his challenge
and once again this film surprises me
with how good it manipulates and takes
advantage of
where your attention is focusing on the
fight between all the different straw
hats while watching luffy's i was
essentially waiting for him to deal the
final blow
but instead through once again great
animation
we watch him struggle and that's when
something happens that i completely
forgot about
barod now sitting in the cannon on the
bear king's creation fires on the
captain of the card pirates
however he dodges and shoots in
retaliation much to luffy's despair
and then jesus there's so much drama in
this film and i'd be lying if i said
that i saw this one coming too
i absolutely didn't and it really caught
me off guard
feeding off of this motivation luffy
uses it to throw bear king into a wall
catching a blast from his cannon
throwing it right back at him the tower
falls and so do the carried pirates
liberating the city beneath and
ultimately the child's
homeland it turns out the ice cream hair
lady is the mother so
that's nice but overall having now
finished this film i can say that my
initial thoughts on it really turned out
to be
wrong with the narrative showing us its
true hand in the second half there's a
lot more going on under the hood in this
film that i once thought going into it
and honestly it impressed me
specifically when compared to movie one
which
while fun felt like an extended episode
of the anime
this on the other hand both on a visual
and even a narrative level somewhat felt
like something one would see in theaters
kind of filled with wonderful
action-packed and expressive animation
adventures on clockwork island is a film
i would say even new fans of the series
could enjoy
this video is brought to you by
ridge.com tnm
most people are still using wallets
designed in the 1990s and in this modern
landscape it's seriously outdated
and i should know i've been using the
same wallet since i was 15 years old and
that means i've been using some outdated
wallet for the last 14 years of my life
in the same way phones have gotten more
practical and compact over the last few
decades so too of wallets and it's
honestly made a massive difference to my
pockets
personally i hate having cumbersome
items in there and this totally fits my
new lifestyle
it holds up to 12 separate cards plus
room for cash and there's over 30
different colors and styles including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium to
choose from
and if that wasn't enough to win you
over yet check out their 30
000 5 star reviews the durable nature of
each of these wallets comes with a
lifetime warranty so
in theory you could buy this one wallet
and carry it for life and the rich team
have told me that they're so confident
that you like it that they'll actually
let you test drive it for 45 days
that means you can send it back for a
full refund if it's not up to your own
standards
right now there's a special offer going
where you can get 10 off with
free worldwide shipping and returns and
you can get all of this by going to
ridge.com
tnm and using the coupon code tnm
link is in the description next up
one piece chopper's kingdom in the
strange animal island
i didn't like this movie one piece
chopper's kingdom
in the strange animal island is a 2d
animated feature film that made me want
to stop watching these films
released on march 3rd 2002 it was once
again produced by toy animation and
written by the same fellow that wrote
the prior film it's 56 minutes of what i
consider boring
and felt completely different to the
last film despite it being written and
directed by the exact same people
they arrive in an area chopper is
crowned their king because of his devil
fruit powers and
the artwork in this one makes it look as
though everyone is
sort of coated in oil it's not something
i think
looks very nice personally the plot is
pretty simple the bad guys want horns
and
they call them horn eaters there's a boy
on the island that gets stranded there
after his father was killed by
some evil biologist i don't know these
folks on the island seem to be playing
music to get these big creatures to
charge and
knock out the ones with horns and then
they cut off their horns
all to feed their master who seems to be
looking for particular horns to grant a
particular effect
after this the straw hats and these
evildoers encounter each other
where they exchange in what i've dubbed
the super ultra mega
exposition scene in this scene nami's
plan to get information out of them
subtly fails and therefore she has to
explain it to all of us
every new character describes themselves
and pretty much reinforces the trend of
all villains in these films being
terrible and
the big bad pretty much goes on a
two-minute spiel
talking about his plans and how they've
been implemented thus far
he does this despite not wanting to tell
them anything
i hate scenes like this this is a movie
show me the plan in action
such that i understand it stop shouting
the plot at me
this big bad guy with the violin luffy
then begins going nuts and knocks them
into a ravine and
ultimately safety this entire
conversation was
wall wall-to-wall exposition in the most
clunky way and if that wasn't enough
when they fall into the water which is a
considerable distance away from the evil
biologist and his henchmen
they decide to hitch a ride to the
animal king
and would you look who's there in the
forest overlooking their decision to go
it's those exact evil people how did
they even get there
this film also suffers from what feels
like to me
very slow pacing in a nutshell the story
is
chopper gets taken in by the locals as
their king luffy and the gang get
stranded
chopper is asked to solve the island's
problem luffy and them run into the
island's problem
then they run into chopper it's super
simple and really has no extra depth
worth exploring at least none that i
noticed
and so the first 30 minutes felt like 90
minutes to me
the evil dude shows up but once again
luffy can't engage
this time because coincidentally he's
trapped the only other two fighters of
the crew sanji and zoro
in a cave because he's too fat to leave
after eating
and naturally they show up on the scene
only seconds after chopper ran off to
deal with the issue
okay we're almost done we're finally at
the main portion of the film the one
where all the major players get to face
off against the forces of the rival crew
first up is zorro against big old faced
man
second is sanji against stripy slimy
handsome man
and lastly nami and usop deal with the
herd of beasts all of these fights are
easily the highlight of the movie
but really if i'm honest felt really
mediocre
sanji and zoro win after they get beaten
on for most of the fight just by
trying harder it felt really dumb the
main fight however featuring luffy
against the main guy
was sort of cool he's after eating the
golden horns
don't ask it's a long story and has
turned into a big monster the fight is
shot somewhat well too and looks as
though it's received most of the
attention in the film
the animation itself is fun and the
staging is much more tense
chopper tries but fails the kid tries
but fails and then luffy tries again
smashing that no good man's horns
the end to be perfectly honest i didn't
vibe with this one
at all it felt a lot more like an
abridged version of a really boring
filler arc in the anime
than an actual movie with planning and a
large team behind it
so far it's the worst one and the only
one i've actually disliked
you might like this one if you like
chopper but even he doesn't do much
in this film if you're really bored and
love one piece more than life itself
then
you'll love this too but for me it just
wasn't the best
though did look pretty from time to time
despite everyone looking like they're
covered in oil
last up one piece the adventures of dead
end one piece the adventures of dead end
is a 2003 film produced by toei
animation that
is over an hour and a half long this is
by far and away
the best film of the four and i mean by
far
while i enjoyed movie one as a
characterful fun romp it felt more like
an extended episode of the anime
movie 2 was a bit better again the
animation was on another level and the
narrative was surprisingly engaging
specifically towards the end but the
villain and the other antagonists felt
very one note and finally movie 3 was
garbage in my opinion but
this movie 4 feels massive in scope has
superb storyboarding
and honestly elevates every single scene
it has
the writing is great and features some
of my favorite scenes i've seen the
straw hat pirates partake in
and if i'm being honest it's exactly
what i thought a good one piece movie
should look like
from the very first scene it's
abundantly obvious that this film was
made with
considerably more resources than the
prior stormy seas watching from the
perspective of the marines as they
pursue the straw hat pirates
i found this fascinating and incredibly
potent when it came to setting the tone
and establishing these pirates for
would-be first-time viewers
they come off as intimidating and
elusive and that's something this film
does a fantastic job of
establishing the tone of its characters
and divulging information in an elegant
and
engaging way and that's not all this is
one of the most interesting and
effective openings to a film i've seen
comes packaged with this one too
immediately following this scene we
follow this 3d tracking shot which for
the time of 2003
is spectacularly done twisting and
turning through narrow passageways
it really helps to convey this sense
that we are on a pirate-dominated island
passing unsavory customer after unsavory
customer
before finding ourselves in this little
hole in the wall tavern
looking at luffy's wanted poster and
that's when it hit me
just how effective this opening was in
the first two scenes
the film makes the world feel more real
and lived in than perhaps any world i've
been introduced to within an anime the
seas are vast and dangerous the town's
densely populated and teeming with life
world building has been such an integral
part of what makes one piece feel like
one piece and i think this film achieves
that and more within the first
five minutes of the feature unlike manga
or episodic anime they don't have a ton
of time to dedicate to world building
and so
what time they do dedicate to it needs
to be effective
and this totally achieves that it makes
the straw hat crew feel small and yet
there's luffy's poster it shrinks them
and then
elevates them before introducing us to
the crew all sat around the table
having brilliant character exchanges and
the way this is framed from top to
bottom implies a wider more active
environment whether it be while they're
eating chatting or when nami walks up to
the bar
always see the other patrons drinking
chatting and having a good time
this feels like a dingy old hole in the
wall bar and i love
it and while this might be a small thing
i think it's the first line of a movie
taking itself seriously this movie
shows instead of telling us the
exposition for instance remember in the
last film movie three when we had that
super boring and monotonous expository
dump well
we don't get that in this film instead
of the barre man suddenly telling us
that there's a secret passageway
we as an audience are shown some shady
dudes slip him 200 berries before moving
somewhere else
so going in we know that byron knows
something and even while nami is probing
the guy for info on how to get some
quick cash
he barely tells her anything and that
very instance
that very lack of information is what
makes the ultimate reveal of this
underworld pirate town
so engaging and stunning when it is
unveiled and once it is
this movie does something none of the
others did introduce us to new
characters in simple but interesting
ways and
get this the ant would note or boring
now
with that said the big bad of this
feature does share
a borderline inappropriate amount in
common with crocodile from alabasta
from his appearance to the way he speaks
to even how he conducts himself and
don't even get me started on the
similarities between their devil through
abilities
but you know what if you're gonna look
at any one-piece villain for inspiration
it's crocodile so i can at least get on
board with that sort of train of thought
but anyway yes there's a fight scene
and damn is it good helping us get
acquainted with this bruce lee cosplay
dude called shuraya and of course
the big croc himself gaspardi the
choreography here
was fantastic my personal favorite
portion being when shuraya kicks over a
table uses it as cover before jumping
back into some wonderful animation
this is what it looks like when we get
great animation coupled with some
terrific storyboarding you get a
seamless stream of quality that blends
multiple artists cuts of animation
together in a brilliant way this coupled
with some classic and cheeky loofy
dialogue only reaffirms this as my
current favorite film
through this scene in the pirate
underworld we learn that there's a
massive race and that winner gets
300 million berries gaspardi is the
current favorite obviously and the
presence he has within this underworld
can be felt whenever someone brings up
his name
nami confident as ever and really
wanting the money
signs them up and naturally luffy is
more than excited to participate
one clever writing choice i noticed also
was to utilize robin's shady past to the
script's advantage
any time the crew had a query while they
did bother locals and asked them
robin was able to answer many of their
questions they had as she reveals that
she had already been there at one point
in her life when she was younger it's
subtle but it's a nice way of including
a character's backstory in a believable
way to benefit the script in terms of
its pacing this film also utilizes the
subplot mechanic
wonderfully we see the point of view of
an old man and this young kid
as they're aboard gaspari's ship the old
man is in a terrible condition and the
kid only wants to help him and gaspardi
forces him to do it on his own forcing
the kid to run off into the night to try
to find money for medicine when the next
day arrives luffy and the crew are
sailing up this mountain essentially
towards the starting point of this race
and once they get to the top of this
mountain it's a breathtaking shot that
captures
every single individual within the crew
and their personalities
it really makes this race feel wild
dangerous and beautiful
around this time zoro notices that
there's a stowaway in the ship and he
tries to kill zorro and these scenes
with this little kid mingling with the
straw hats are easily the most heartfelt
out of the films i've seen so far
and once luffy and the crew arrived to
where their eternal poses were pointing
to they realized this entire race has
been a trap
rigged by gasparde taking this
motivation to confront him luffy
challenges this little kid and it's
truly touching how he rolls him up
before saying that he will be laying
down his life to help him too
closing in now on the third act of the
film we get a fight between sharaya and
needles
gaspardi's henchmen and it was fantastic
the flow of this fight felt natural it
wasn't anything more than it needed to
be
had some really nice angles and the best
part was it had a great psychological
element to it shuraya had a strategy and
came off as very clever with every
split-second decision he needed to make
to overcome what looked like a stronger
opponent
in needles using the very ship itself to
disarm him and eventually
knock him overboard it's a really great
fight scene that i encourage anyone to
go check out
this also helps to break the trend of
having sanji and zoro attack the lesser
henchmen
instead having them do little bits here
and there to help luffy
out both in physical altercations and
nuanced emotional situations it made for
a much more natural and enjoyable
experience in my opinion as the fight
gets underway between luffy and gasparde
shuraya
starts getting in the way of luffy again
and
get out of the way luffy punches the
ever loving hell out of him to the side
this action of luffy stopping him from
throwing his life away all the while
swelling with the music it really felt
massive and monumental it's a great
moment
the fight that ensues is also helped
greatly by the fact that luffy's hat is
in tatters and the weather is
tragically bad though i will say i
thought the battle between shuria and
needles was more exciting and well
handled
luffy vs gasparde is still a commendable
effort and makes use of some clever
tactics in its own right however soon it
comes to our attention that the old man
is choosing to stay below deck despite
the impending cyclone and it looks like
he's willing to die alongside his boiler
that he worked with his entire life when
the little kid learns the news he
loses it once again leading to zoro
having to knock him out
and it's at this point chopper reveals
that he was in fact
a little girl all along the camera then
shifts perfectly to shuraya once again
signifying that she is in fact his
little sister
this totally took me by surprise and
with the worsening situation the cyclone
impending and the ship
effectively being a ticking time bomb
thanks to the boiler the tension rises
to a fever pitch
this was such a fun portion of this film
and
then
the ending to this film is sufficiently
large scale for the occasion and the
dialogue is snappy and clever this is
peak
luffy dialogue he's snarky brazen and
lighthearted however
one thing that did take away from this
altercation for me
was the fact it shared so so much with
the crocodile luffy fight instead of
turning to sand he can turn to liquid
sugar and instead of water luffy uses
flour to combat this ability
and really it ends in a similar way too
which is a shame because i really
thought this film had enough going for
it to justify its
own ending free of any comparison to
existing material in the manga what's
more is that despite the fight being
massive with explosions and sinking
ships
the old man ends up saving both luffy
and
shuria he does this despite needing
medicine earlier in the film and even
later on in the film barely being able
to walk down a set of stairs
this felt very forced if i'm being
honest and was the only portion of the
film where i felt
i was cheated somewhat with that said
the ending proper is heartfelt and has
some typical one-piece philosophy
look to the future trust in those that
you love and try your absolute hardest
to achieve your dreams
despite that hiccup at the very end and
the numerous similarities between croc
and gaspari i sincerely think that this
film is more than worth a look at
even if you're not a fan of one piece
it's worth checking out you're sure to
find something here that's both
enjoyable and
engaging i had a blast with this one and
that makes four films next week i'll be
tackling movies five
six seven and 10. i'm skipping movies 8
and 9 because i'm only covering original
news stories there's no recaps here
folks
but that'll do it for this week's video
i've been totally not mark i'll see you
all next week and thank you all
so much for watching
[Music]
you